diese geschichte geht ans herz und zwar
buchstäblich sie handelt von einem der
jeden tag über leben und tod entscheidet
und das ausgerechnet bei denjenigen bei
denen das leben gerade erst angefangen
hat
komm nachholen
kleiner bär
komm nach haus
[Musik]
weise
das nachholen
lampen leuchten
der tag ist
jasmin ist vor knapp vier monaten mit
einem herzfehler zur welt gekommen
sie hat ein loch in der scheidewand
zwischen den beiden herzkammern dieser
defekt kann nur eine operation beheben
ein routine-eingriff ein schwerer bühne
treten wird jasmin operieren
hat der nachwelt sich ein normales kind
sein wie bei allen operationen vor allem
herzoperationen es gibt ein kleines
risiko schätzen das risiko nicht sehr
groß zwischen ein und zwei prozent dass
wir ein großes problem haben kennen
das hat sie ja zum beispiel also bei
größeren problemen ist kann sein dass
das kind die ganze operation allein das
nicht überlebt das kann man immer noch
sehen oder das ist ein gehirn wurde ein
herzproblem gibt hier das ist ein
problem von sauerstoff zum beispiel oder
hat man es auch diese zwei
komplikationen würden die lebensqualität
reduzieren und das blut fließt von
operationen am offenen herzen sind
anders als früher keine lotterie mehr
für den eingriff von jasmin gilt eine
erfolgsquote von 98 prozent
die statistik macht köstlich wirken aber
wie sollen eltern auch nur den gedanken
aushalten dass das eigene kind zu den
zwei prozent gehören könnte wo etwas
schief läuft
sie wird alles machen können sport eine
familie haben einmal um so das ist
wirklich eine normalerweise wird in ein
ausgezeichnetes resultat aussagen der
nachwelt sich ein normales kind sein
ja
sonst sagen
er ist der termin jetzt wirklichkeit
gern dort mit sicherheit
[Musik]
es ist aber gut nochmal ist also das ist
ja in operationen die wir extrem
regelmäßig mal und die idee entrinnen
mehr als die kinder abschluss
das muss man mal richtig ein schwieriger
moment für die eltern aber auch für den
chirurgen er muss aushalten dass alle
hoffnungen auf ihm liegen und ein fehler
eigentlich absolut unverzeihlich ist mit
emotionen sind auch wichtig finde ich
also das muss man auch halten weil es
ist es gibt immerhin der arbeit für eine
gewisse nicht routine rein gestrickte
ablauf aber das muss man ihnen auch gut
machen auch die kleine einzuleiten und
ich finde das ist auch wichtig man hat
mit diesem eltern aber wenn ich ein kind
gesprochen man weiß wer das ist und man
bemüht sich nicht mehr und ich sage nach
der incentive ist dass man wirklich hat
es ganz gut macht wenn es nur auch ein
bisschen ein gesicht gibt und nicht nur
ein herz die fragen die sich stellen
sind sofort existenziell
das gehört zum arbeitsalltag eines
herzchirurgen eine tägliche
gratwanderung zwischen routine und
emotionen
die kleine jasmin wird gut vier stunden
lang operiert werden
britta ist anders als viele andere
karten von anfang bis schluss des
eingriffs dabei vom ersten schnitt bis
zum schließen der naht die atmosphäre im
operationssaal ist ruhig und entspannt
wie immer weit mit stummer verständigung
beinahe könnte man vergessen dass sich
eine breitere hier mit skalpell und
schwere gerade zum herzen eines babys
vorarbeitet hier haben wir was sie
möchte kann ich mag was schön aussieht
also so ist ist und dass er es gibt dass
es ist es nicht ein flaches organ ist
ist wirklich dreidimensional
es gibt schöne kurven unglaublich schön
der sie noch kurven es gibt keine gerade
linie in einem herzens und wenn ich eine
rekonstruktion gemacht habe und man
fühlt dass er es wieder auf und ich sehe
alle kuschelstimmung sind so schön dann
nicht so das bringt so ein gutes gefühl
ich bin überzeugt einmal oder als kultur
wenn er fertig ist und sieht das ist
wirklich schön haus nicht hat das kleine
schicke jasmins operation ist eine so
genannte maschine ein eingriff bei dem
die herz lungen maschine zum einsatz
kommt das bedeutet dass das herz vom
blutkreislauf abgekoppelt und komplett
stillgelegt wird die maschine übernimmt
die funktion des herzens damit der
chirurg am ruhigen nicht pulsierenden
herzen arbeiten kann
wir werden das hier sind die steuersätze
neben kaltes blut in hessen das
hessische aufhören zu starten also wir
werden diese weiße linie er schien
gewirkt flach sein wie ein wirklich ein
stillstand und das ist was wir wollen
für eine halbe stunde chemiker der
korrektur wieder tatsächlich
herzstillstand erst jetzt konkretere den
patch das pflaster annehmen und damit
das loch zwischen den herz kommen
schließen
eine breitere gilt als sehr geschickter
chirurg wie ein guter fußballer der über
zwei starke füße verfügt kann trete mit
beiden händen operieren
kein wunder ist er auch ein guter
fussballer jetzt wenn ich diese klänge
wegnehmen will dass es in normalen blut
durch geblutet sein und es wird langsam
wieder schlagen so die farbe hinter sich
jetzt fließt einfach das normale blut im
herz man es liegt die farbe kommt gut
und das jetzt während anfangen wieder zu
schlagen scheint sich
es bewegt eigentlich hin jetzt
so ist sehr langsam
[Musik]
das teilt jetzt braucht noch einlegen
sekundentakt immer schneller bis sie
sich wieder und wir werden die cdu zehn
minuten beachten ist dass er sich
vollständig erholt hat und nach etwa
zehn minuten er wieder im kreislauf
übernehmen können
okay wie darauf machen
eine halbe stunde lang war jasmin kaatz
ausgeschaltet stillgelegt mit dem
abkoppeln der herz-lungen-maschine fängt
für das baby gewissermaßen ein neues
leben an
mit einem fordern vollständig intakten
herzen
[Musik]
er operiere leidenschaftlich gern sagt
grüne petra der moment aber indem er den
eltern von einem gelungenen angriff
berichten könne sei jedes mal besonders
befriedigend
wir sind 60
es ist es ist gut gegangen jasmin geht
es jetzt auch die intensivstation und
ich nehme mir ein vielleicht in einer
stunde erkennen sie vorbeikommen und es
würde auch dabei sein
okay okay okay danke den eindruck dass
die menschen die würde uns relativ groß
und die polin monat knapp her auch die
abteilung für herzchirurgie gibt es am
zürcher kinderspital seit 2004 300
operationen werden hier jedes jahr
durchgeführt herzchirurgie sei
teamarbeit betonte preetz vorbei die
zeiten der macho kollegen die
kinderherzchirurgie ist so etwas wie
eine königsdisziplin und gilt als
technisch extrem anspruchsvoll
man stelle sich vor dass herzkranzgefäß
eines neugeborenen zum beispiel hat
einen durchmesser von gerade mal einem
halben millimeter
[Musik]
paris eine breitere wird immer wieder in
die französische hauptstadt zurück
diesmal für einen ärztekongress
spätabends nach einem langen tag im
operationssaal 33 ist das großstadtleben
gewohnt bevor er den chefposten am
zürcher kinderspital übernahm arbeitete
der jurassier verschiedentlich im
ausland und paris aber auch in london
und in new york dort operiert der mitten
in manhattan im berühmten bellevue
hospital auf der notfallstation ein
großartiges thoma feld für chirurgen
neben den üblichen notfällen tag und
nacht patienten mit stichverletzungen
und schusswunden
[Musik]
neben der chirurgisch 'nen verfolgte
bretter ebenso zielstrebig eine
wissenschaftliche karriere publizierte
viel und ist deshalb auch gern gesehener
referent und kongressen
die ausflüge und die kongresse sind für
breitere fast ein bisschen fehlen auch
mit seiner ex frau und den beiden
inzwischen erwachsenen töchtern machte
der kommt nämlich nie länger als eine
woche urlaub hier ist rainer brettner
aufgewachsen im äußersten zipfel des
loader in bangkok zusammen mit sechs
geschwistern auf einem bauernhof
die sieben kinder mussten mit anpacken
auf dem elterlichen betrieb hier sagt
rinne praet habe er gelernt dass ein
arbeitstag durchaus mehr als acht
stunden haben kann und hier habe geübt
seine hände zu gebrauchen diesem traktor
rat vater trete 1968 angeschafft und mit
dem starten des motors sind sofort die
ganzen kindheitserinnerungen wieder
präsent jetzt leben sie in einer
komplett anderen welt das ist so ja die
welt ist daran das manchmal ich denke da
haben also ich war wichtig ein country
boy ich kannte ja hier vor allem hier
alle alle bäume oder so auch die dass er
ist ganz anders ihr oder dort und ich
konnte der unterschied schon verstehen
und so und jetzt sehe ich das fast nicht
mehr
aber gut ich habe mich schon in ein paar
jahren werde ich nicht zurückgekommen
ich glaube nicht dass ich also ewig in
einer stadt leben werde von der arbeit
machen sie auch etwas komplett anderes
hätten sie sich das geträumt das kind ja
es ist komplett anders doch schon werden
hier schauen sie mal wohnt so diese
maschinen hatten eine paranoia und
chinas dahin hat das repariert und das
ist größeren sachen und so oder man
schon man muss schon diese mega nicht
verstehen und auch mit seine hände
arbeiten also mit uns arbeiten wäre nach
jährige arbeitet schon aber auch die
arbeit ist nicht genau gleich das ist so
ja was glauben sie nicht so gelaufen
[Musik]
aber alles ausgemacht und wieder zu
sagen rät petra hat also einen
pragmatischen zugang zur chirurgie und
der geschickte umgang mit dem messer
legt durchaus in der familie
die verbundenheit mit der familie ist
immer noch sehr eng auch wenn petra seit
jahren weit weg vom mann ein großes
problem hat und auch so ich kann immer
meinen eltern meinem bruder schwester
anrufen und ich weiß schon auch wenn ich
einen fehler gemacht habe sie sie
unterstützen mich hat sie die karriere
des blutes überrascht
es ist natürlich toll aber es hat mich
schon sehr überrascht als wir kind waren
hatten wir nie über unsere zukunft
gesprochen
und kurz vor der matur hat er mir gesagt
er würde medizin studieren
und ich habe immer gedacht ja er hat es
einen weg gefunden weil das war eine
gute mischung von von lehre und auch von
hand arbeiten
genau wie der traktor weckt auch der
fussball kindheitserinnerungen zusammen
mit seinen brüdern hat rené trete jahre
lang beim fc buch in der ersten liga
gespielt
das
[Musik]
unterwegs im auftrag einer prinzessin
drei bis viermal im jahr unternimmt
grüne petra eine reise nach monaco
auf einladung von prinzessin caroline
sie unterhält eine humanitäre stiftung
die herzkranke kinder aus aller welt
nach monaco bringt und hier in einem
spital das diesem luxus hotel
angeschlossen ist operieren lässt
getreten ist einer von vier gurken die
solche operationen unentgeltlich
durchführen
[Musik]
das operationsplan gramm ist meistens
streng bis zu vier große eingriffe an
einem tag
die meisten kinder kommen aus afrika
ihre herzerkrankungen sind so ernst dass
sie in ihren heimatländern kaum
behandelt werden können
ziel ist es aber dass die kinder nach
einer einzigen operation geheilt sind
[Musik]
das eine gute art von humanitärem
engagement
es ist schon etwas diese kinder
profitieren sehr viel von unserer
operationen nochmals wir nehmen kinder
die vielleicht nicht zu komplexe
missbildungen haben und nach eine oder
auch zwei operationen in singen so
gesagt gesund dass sie wäre total
interim im leben in sozialem leben
integriert sein können also für diese
kinder ist man ein risiko unterschied
am besten wäre wenn sich die leute die
lokalen personen doch da auch ausbilden
neben seinem einsatz wie das
monegassische hilfswerk unterhält eine
breitere in der schweiz eine eigene
herzstiftung le petit coeur
dafür reist er einmal im jahr zwei
wochen nach mosambik und operiert dort
gemeinsam mit einheimischen chirurgen
herzkranke kinder heute operiert der
schweizerin monaco als erster rashid
einen achtjährigen aus burkina faso
der junge hat ein loch im herzen sowie
eine verengte stelle die erweitert
werden muss ein mitarbeiter der stiftung
von prinzessin caroline hat den jungen
vor einigen tagen hier nach monaco
geholt jetzt liegt er tausende kilometer
von zu hause entfernt unter dem messer
minute pedro muss zwei patches zwei
pflaster annehmen eines davon am
schlagenden herzen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was ist eigentlich das herz für jemanden
der jeden tag mit hineinblickt als tirol
bin ich arbeite wie heute morgen es ist
plötzlich nur noch anlagen komplexe
geometrie komplexe anatomie immer noch
sehr schön wirklich zeigen und
nur gut dass ich glaube ich kann sagen
ich vertrete das gut und vielleicht es
gibt mehr als nur ein geologisches
verhalten ist jeder mensch weiß dass er
es ist auch das zentrum des lebens liebe
emotionen sammelt sich alle da und das
ist eine spezielle funktionen rolle
und sie sind sich dessen bewusst wenn
sie ein herz operieren
also wenn ich operiere das ist noch
einmal dass das alle diese diese
dimensionen kommen ein bisschen manchmal
wenn ich ein problem aber plötzlich mein
gott was passiert jetzt die so aber so
lange es geht wie geplant ich bin auf
meine trike und die skizze in diese
richtung dann ist wirklich ein organ wie
gesagt dass ich glaube ich kann sagen
ich kenne sehr gut kann auch vorsehen
nachkommen wird und solange es ist in
dieser richtung geht das gut
und da diese emotionale komponente habe
ich nicht ihn kurz solange es gut geht
chirurgie also eine handwerkliche
tätigkeit ohne besondere emotionalität
sobald aber etwas schiefläuft ändert
sich das schlagartig momente die räume
trete auch schon erlebt hat und die sich
ganz tief in seiner erinnerung
eingegraben haben momente über die
chirurgen selten sprechen und die räte
den nächsten gang in den operationssaal
auch schon sehr schwer gemacht haben
ein kind kommt auf die welt und wir
wissen wenn wir nichts machen er lebt
noch einfach sagen wir machen alles was
möglich ist
es geht nicht da haben wir nicht habe
ich nicht ein schlechtes gefühl auch
wenn ich einen groben fehler hätte
gemacht hat als sonst sagt okay wir
haben alles probiert es nicht gegangen
das schwierigste ist ein kind das hat
ein herzproblem vielleicht nicht so groß
wenn man sich ja mit einer operation wir
werden die lebensqualität und
lebenserwartung dieses kinder verbessern
und da hat man das problem
das sind die alpträume also dass das in
die situationen die mir ein paar mal
diese frage gestellt hat im jahr will
ich das wirklich dieser stress warum
mache ich auch das wäre wenn es so etwas
passiert ist und es ist mir passiert und
wie sind sie damit umgegangen immer
extrem steht also das waren es gibt eine
reihe von 230 nicht wo man nicht gut
schlafen kann
ich habe sogar meinen programmen den
wichtigsten tagen geändert heute nicht
mehr in eine stresssituation in diesem
moment
leben und machen auch manchmal also
wochenlang monate land das gesicht der
mutter kommt mit kopf und so antara die
operation
es ist unglaublich wie eine operation
kann den kopf lange bleiben also wenn
man ein movie sieht und man kann fast
die zwei stunden in den kopf drehen
können und das kommt ihnen diese nicht
der haie vor allem wenn man einen moment
ein fehler gemacht hat oder etwas das
nicht geklappt hat und diesem moment
kommt immer noch im kreis
[Musik]
heute ist alles gut gegangen vier kinder
hat dünne bretter operiert
[Musik]
rashid der junge aus burkina faso wird
in zwei wochen nach afrika zu seiner
familie heimkehren können
[Musik]
hat sie der beruf auch ein bisschen
verändert klar also nicht nur den beruf
das leben einfach nein ich mache diese
theorie seit 20 jahren jetzt schon
sicher ist auch viel passiert in meinem
leben ich habe kinder gehabt und so
erfolge niederlagen und und da sind sie
sehr viel aber in meinem beruf arbeiten
wäre auch hier um heeren mit leben und
tod und da muss man damit umgehen und
sind extrem starke gefühle manchmal und
gut vielleicht komme ich ein bisschen
philosophisch aber das macht leute noch
mehr bescheiden finde ich man spürt auch
seine grenzen man spürt oder die
menschlichen grenzen man kann nicht
alles wir sind erste wir schon viele
patienten aber wir müssen mit der natur
arbeiten wir gegen die natur arbeitet
das geht nicht
und dann gibt es noch das leben aus rat
des spitals und die andere leidenschaft
von retro den fußball aber auch die
teilt er oft mit arbeitskollegen an
einem sommerabend wenn er seine engsten
mitarbeiter zu sich nach hause einlädt
auf die dachterrasse seiner wohnung nur
ein steinwurf vom zürcher kinderspital
entfernt sich nicht mit ihrem fußball
spielt oder in europa oder ins kino
ja das schon eigentlich einfach gut das
ist auch mein
meine leidenschaft die diese arbeit und
ich hab ich vergnügen also ich bin froh
wenn ich in die arbeit gehen und wenn
ich aufstehe und für den weg zum später
bin ich schon froh ich denke auf diese
operation sie kommen wie ich das machen
werde dargelegt mit dem thema wenn wir
das diskutieren organisieren wenn das
ganz gut geht wenn alles schön sie das
bringt schon ein unglaublich gutes
gefühl
kommt nach vorn
nein
rb
komm nach haus
kommt
die lampen leuchten
der tag ist raus
karl schwind nach hause
er erfand
läuft nach haben
[Musik]
weise
rast nach hause
die lampen leuchten
der tag ist
[Musik]